hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast two dimensional and three
dimensional cell culture does dimension
really matter he's presented by Akademi
Kaulitz PhD a postdoctoral research
fellow at pharmacy in Northwest
University South Africa I am Judy or or
collaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Kaulitz
I will now turn the presentation over to
her thank you for that wonderful
introduction Judy today I hope to answer
a few questions regarding two and
three-dimensional cell culturing and why
the right model is of utmost importance
when answering complex research
questions in a world where heart disease
tuberculosis HIV AIDS and cancer are
among the top ten causes of death we as
researchers are faced with complex
research questions it is our mission to
try and develop the best known them
sorry it is our mission to try and
understand underlying disease mechanisms
and attempt to develop new promising
drug treatments to help us in the
search we look to in vitro models to
better understand these diseases the
type of in vitro model implemented will
determine our successes and this is
where salary dimension comes into play
let us look at the human body the human
body is a complex three-dimensional
system with organ systems communicating
with each other by bio chemical and
mechanical sicne there is also
intracellular communication between the
various cell types within each specific
organ and you also have intracellular
communication within individual cells
two-dimensional cell culturing has been
around for decades with the first
attempt at traditional cell culturing in
1885 it has been an essential tool in
the elucidation of many disease states
the culturing conditions are highly
controlled with a high degree of
homogeneity and reproducibility allowing
for the discovery of molecular
mechanisms the system has also
contributed significantly to our
knowledge of tumor biology whilst
emanating cancer research in terms of
drug discovery and development and it's
a simple and cost effective method
unfortunately the system also has its
limitations keep in mind that this is an
isolated homogeneous population of cell
far removed from the truth tumor
microenvironment the system lacks cell
to cell communication cell matrix
interactions and most importantly tissue
specific architecture furthermore cells
grown in 2d undergo phenotypic and
genotypic adaptations to in vitro
conditions they are also accumulating
mutations and is limited in terms of
cited toxicity Isis the working window
for experiments is usually between two
two to seven days limiting you to only
acute studies in terms of toxicity on
the other hand animal models have been
used for many
in research and drug discovery and
remained a prerequisite in preclinical
drug screening according to the fda
cancer mouse models have revolutionized
our ability to study gene expression and
protein function and more closely
resemble the human physiology
however these models tend to be
expensive and time-consuming furthermore
animal models too frequently fail to
reflect the true human to burp biology
these models are in some instances
immunocompromised and presents with
species and sex differences also not all
cancer types have a suitable animal
model yet and most importantly they come
with ethical and moral considerations
with the establishment of
three-dimensional cell culture systems
it was found that three-dimensional cell
culturing offers a better correlation to
this in beaver situation in three
dimensional dimensional cell cultures
cells find themselves in a more natural
geometrical and morphological shape
resulting in some instances in the
formation of in vivo like tissue
structures that provide more clinically
relevant data that is more
representative of the in vivo condition
and comparable to animal studies due to
the unnatural two-dimensional micro
environments of cells in 2d important
metabolism and biochemical features are
altered that has an influence on
pharmacological drug responses these
geometric and morphological differences
influences the cytoskeleton gene and
protein expression that are responsible
for cellular responses one of the most
striking differences between 2d and 3d
culturing is the culturing time 2d
cultures have a limited working window
usually days to weeks or some 3d systems
have working unit windows from weeks to
months this allows not only for acute
short-term studies but also long-term
chronic studies
various three-dimensional culture
systems are available and it should be
stressed that no one method is superior
to the other and that your research
question and available resources will
determine which system you will employ
three-dimensional systems can broadly be
classified into static and dynamic or
irrigated systems static systems as the
classification suggests is static
non-moving systems these include but are
not limited to hanging drop cultures
forced floating devices micro molding
and printing devices Galactus related
substrates 3d scaffolds and primary Oh
dishes while dynamic or irrigated
systems include spin-off lasts
microfluidic devices microgravity and
rotating bio reactors here at the
Northwest University our research
focuses on the multicellular spheroids
grown in rotating bio reactors a
spheroid is defined as a spherical
symmetric aggregate of cells and
allergies to tissue spirits are seen as
heterogeneous aggregates with cells that
are proliferating Akio hastened and
retained the 3d architecture with the
capability to reestablish the tissue
specific functions these multicellular
swearwords are capable of mimicking in
vivo processes such as embryogenesis
morphogenesis and organogenesis and
processes through possesses several in
vivo like features of tumors including
Saudi cell interaction hypoxia drug
penetration responses and resistance as
well as the production and/or deposition
of extracellular matrix in a laboratory
we employ the Salva verbum system there
is a kleiner step based system using by
reuse
rotating bioreactors to grow our swear
words a kleiner set is a rotating device
that has been around since the 1920s
originally designed to allow plants to
experience equal amounts of
gravitational pull over 360 degrees in
this way there is little to no
gravitational pull on the plant allowing
the plant to overcome instances of
positive phototropism and geotropism the
same principles account for cells grown
in a climate that based by reactor in
that the gravitational pull is lessened
on the soul the Sal vivo bomb system is
a next-generation Kleinert set based
system that comes with a driving unit
environmental control and a wireless
control system with one of the most
user-friendly interfaces Suites
organized
noids for use for this system can be
created by various means in our
laboratories we prefer to work with
Agrawal plates from stem cell
technologies and sodium alginate the
rotating bio reactors severe by survival
our fixed volume by reactors that come
already assembled these bio reactors
have a salt chamber with two openings
that allow for sampling and medium
exchange and a water chamber with a wick
to generate humidity the cell chamber
and water chamber is separated by 0.2
micron membrane and the gas exchange
labyrinth on the water chamber allows
for optimum oxygen and carbon dioxide
exchange because this is a closed system
instances of contamination and
infections within the cultures are kept
to a minimum so to produce spirits in
our labs we prepare a cell suspension
from cells grown in 2d and then we see
the cells into agrawal plates the arable
plates allows us to generate up to 1200
sized controlled spirits per well
we then allow the suspension to form
swear words within the agar wells for 24
hours after 24 hours
the spirits are removed from the agar
balls and placed in a petri dish the
spirits are then inspected
microscopically to determine the quality
compactness and roundest after that
spirits are transferred to the rotating
bioreactors which is then placed on the
bummer rotating system spirits are
maintained by daily speed adjustments
and media replenishment
swarek's produced in this way can have
physiological functionality for a period
of 42 days with seward's reaching a
metabolic equilibrium around 21 days
this means that your experimental design
is now not lament that to 5 or 7 days as
with two-dimensional cultures but can
now be conducted over a 21 day period we
make use of various three-dimensional
models produced from a variety of cell
lines in our lab we mostly focus on
cancer research reported toxicity and
drug by transformation one of our most
well characterized spirit models is our
help you to see through a sewer model
that we employ inhibit toxicity studies
most of the work on this world model was
done by collaborators dr. christow
Brzezinski and professor Stephen Fei
from South Viva one of the most
fascinating insights into the [ __ ] c3h
words came from the Silurians sweets
section and imaged with an electron
microscope the image on your screen was
second over tweeting one day old head G
2 C 3 a spheroid electron microscopy
revealed microscopic structures within
the spheroid similar to that of in vivo
leather tissues namely biochemically
sinusoid channels with
microvilli and even glycogen granules
work done on the FG 2c 3a Seward grown
in microgravity rotating by reactors
found that these zeros remain for
geologically stable for a period of 42
days this provides us with a
metabolically competent homeostatic cell
model that permits us to determine drug
toxicity and mode of drug action the
evaluation of biomarkers as well as the
study of system biology that requires
metabolic functions to be stable for a
long time period these spirits were also
found to undergo significant changes
within every aspect of their cellular
metabolism oxidation transport growth
and morphology that serves as the
foundation of architectural functional
and physiological differences within
cells other than the 3d cell culture
development our lab also focuses on the
evaluation of traditional herbal
medicine for use as potential lead
compounds and also to determine safety
in terms of hepatotoxicity
traditional herbal medicine and
commercially available medicine are
widely used in South Africa many
patients still consult a traditional
healer and due to the natural origin of
these traditional herbal medicines many
believe that they are safe even safer
than former surgical products available
however this is not true as a herbal or
medicinal medicinal plant is composed of
various constituents as opposed to
appear active pharmaceutical to this
extent we decided to determine the
possible label verbal hepatic toxicity
of a crude aqueous extract from
commercially available
seismo Luba moon de lourdes 'm also
known as zara as one of the most popular
traditional medicines in south africa we
also decided we want to determine which
sister
F G to c3 ace grown in traditional flag
culture or FG to use c 3 a's grown as 3d
swards
or an in vivo sprog Dooley rad model
will provide us with the most accurate
and insightful information in regards to
her ball her pots to toxicity so we set
up two experiments in the first we
treated TD cultures and 3d spheroid
cultures for a period of 96 hours with
daily dosages of bazzara and measured
physiological parameters then retreated
3d swirl cultures and this frog dolly
rat model with Ozora for 21 days the
setup of each experiment is shown in
detail in the following slides for our
first experiment with the
two-dimensional psychologist we set of 5
experimental groups in 96 well plates
cells were seated at a density of 3
thousand cells per well and we measured
physiological parameters namely
intracellular ATP extracellular
adenylate kinase levels and protein
content the experimental groups were as
follow a crude bizarro extract at 200
350 500 and 750 milligrams per kilogram
and an untreated control group the drug
treatment was initiated six hours of the
ceiling and all experimental groups were
treated for 96 hours for the
three-dimensional experiment that we
compared to the previous two dimensional
experiment [ __ ] c-38 spheroids were
prepared using a greebles
as previously discussed and allowed to
grow until 21 days to achieve metabolic
equilibrium with in sets of five
experimental groups in bioreactors each
containing exactly 239 21-day old suits
to ensure that we have sufficient
material for analysis the
there are mental groups consist of the
following bazzara aqueous extract at the
selected concentrations 200 350 500 and
750 milligrams per kilogram as well as a
untreated control the physiological
parameters namely protein content
intracellular ATP and extracellular a.k
were measured in all experimental groups
for a duration of 96 hours for the
comparison between the FG 2 C 3 a 3d
model and the in vivo sprog dawley rad
model the experiments were set up as
follow for the 3d model fall experiments
or groups were prepared with each group
consisting of four biological replicates
in individual bioreactors and each
bioreactor containing 207 swear words
the experimental groups consisted of
spirits treated with Azara at various
concentrations 200 and 250 milligrams
per kilogram sweets treated with sodium
valproate
at 10 grams per kilogram to serve as a
positive control for her party toxicity
and spirits in normal growth medium as
the untreated control group the known
HIPAA toxic for prog acid concentration
was based on a value below they cute
little threshold of 20 milligrams per
milligram protein in spirits as
determined by fate and residence key for
geological parameters namely
intracellular ATP a k' and cellular
growth was evaluated at 24-hour
intervals dosages were minutes
administered at 48 hour intervals for a
duration of 21 days the in vivo study
was approved by the animal care ethics
committee of the Northwest University
prior to initiation of the study if
anyone wishes to see this ethical
approval you are more than welcome to
email me afterwards
foresters for the study specific
pathogen free male and females frog
dolly rats were obtained from the
Northwest University
Boreum weighing between 150 and 250
grams and aged seven to eight weeks the
taste substances tested on the the this
product the early model were consisted
of 200 and 250 milligrams per kilogram
Lazzara and 300 milligrams per kilogram
valproic acid as positive control and
then a normal control group receiving
only the vehicle the taste solutions
were administered by means of oral
coverage at 21 as 21 single dosages in
24-hour intervals on day 7 14 and 21 a
sample population of rats 3 ml and 3
female from each group were euthanized
by means of decapitation and terminal
blood samples were collected for serum
chemistry analysis the results of these
two experiments were very insightful for
the 2d versus 3d experiment we first
evaluated the protein content as it
provides us with growth as a function of
time and it also enables us to express
all of our results in relation to the
protein content the figure on the Left
depicts the average protein content per
experimental group for the 2d
experiments we observed growth
inhibition for all the experimental
groups treated with Ozora
when the protein content was compared to
that of the untreated control group the
experimental groups treated with 200 and
500 milligram per kilogram extract
showed more sustained growth although
slower proliferation appears to have
occurred in comparison to the untreated
control the 350 and 750 milligram per
kilogram extract treatment group showed
a great measure of growth inhibition
from time point 48 hours when compared
to that of the untreated control group
as well as other experimental groups at
time point 72 hours the 750 milligram
per kilogram extract treatments induced
significant growth inhibition when
compared to other groups the untreated
control group data correlates well with
previously published data suggesting
that the doubling time of Hep C 2 C 3 a
cells in exponential growth to be 3 days
and the optimal time for determining
cellular effects is within this time
frame this also suggests that
experimental conditions in 2d culture
differ from day today and its usefulness
is limited to the first 72 hours the
untreated control group group growth
characteristics correlates well with
previously published data confirming the
non stable experimental conditions in 2d
culture especially for the first 72
hours the protein content of the 3d
swearwords are shown on the right from
the protein data we noticed that the
swear itz experienced statistically
significant growth inhibition at time
points 48 72 and 96 hours following
treatment with Lazzara
at concentrations 350 500 and 750
milligrams per kilogram when compared to
the control group thus where it's
receiving 200 milligrams per kilogram
extract showed moderate growth with a
significant growth inhibition of the 96
hours on this side we can see the ATP
data obtained from 2d cell cultures
graphically depicted in the figure on
the Left showing the average
intracellular ATP levels in terms of
average protein content normalized to
the untreated control group within the
first 24 hour post treatment the
intracellular ATP levels increased
noticeably for three of the experimental
groups treated with Azara
relative to the control group between
time point 24 and 48 hours all the
experimental groups showed intracellular
ATP levels similar to that of the
untreated control group however at some
point 48 hours
there was an increase in the amount of
intracellular ATP for the several
hundred and 50 milligram per kilogram
treatment group were in compared to the
other experimental groups after 48 hours
the ATP levels increased for three of
the experimental groups 200 350 and 750
milligrams per kilogram with 750
milligrams per kilogram being
significant increased in relation to the
untreated control between 72 and 96
hours the 500 milligram per kilogram
experimental group showed a slight
increase in HCV at 52 hours decreasing
two values below the control at 60 hours
while reaching values similar to the
untreated control group from time point
72 to 96 hours the figure on the right
gives a graphical depiction of the
intracellular ATP levels first spheroid
protein normalized with reference to the
control group within the first four
hours post treatment intracellular ATP
levels decreases noticeably for all
experiments or groups relative to the
control group steadily recovering back
to the untreated control group levels
over 24 hours from 24 hours to 48 hours
there was a dose-dependent increase in
ATP levels for groups treated both 200
350 and 500 milligrams per kilogram
extract reaching values higher than
those of the control group however the
750 milligrams per kilogram experimental
group remained below the control only
reaching the levels similar to the
control at 48 hours 52 hours post
treatment the ATP levels again decreases
in a dose-dependent manner the
experimental groups treated with Azure
extract at dosages of 200 350 and 500
milligrams per kilogram resulted in a
decrease in ATP with each successive
dosage ATP levels increased however to
besan levels or above within 12 hours
this decrease and subsequent increase of
ATP levels noticed throughout the study
may potentially be the result of an
attempt by the cells to recover from the
onslaught of treatment with Ozora it is
important to note that ATP levels for
the 750 milligram per kilogram treatment
group did not recover to the levels of
the control group beyond 48 hours this
suggests impaired magic on do function
brought on by the crude zora aqueous
extract at 750 milligrams per kilogram
adenylate kinase release from the 2d
cell culture model is an indication of
saw death and in this figures we pretty
we expressed it in terms of protein
content as you can see that the 2d cell
cultures is depicted on in the figure on
the left a slight decrease in a caries
released within the first 24 hours is
observed for all experimental groups in
comparison to the untreated control
group at time points 28 and 32 hours all
experimental group showed an aka release
similar to that of the untreated control
group at 48 hours the group's orig
treated with 350 500 and 750 milligrams
per kilogram showed a slight increase in
I care release returning to levels
similar to that of the control group at
time points 52 and 60 hours between 72
and 48 hours there was an overall
increase in a ke release for all the
experimental groups were 350 500 and 750
milligrams per kilogram reaching
statistically significant increases at
time point 96 hours when compared to the
untreated control group the figure on
the right shows the akin release data
for the 3d steroids and indicates an
initial increase in a K within the first
four hours post treatment for all
experimental groups and the subsequent
decrease over the 24 hours when compared
to the untreated control at 28 hours
first Street
aka gain increased while steadily
decreasing over next 48 hours and
throughout the study two levels below
the untreated control for all the
experimental groups however 750
milligrams per kilogram extract treated
resulted in a steady increase in a ke
release at 96 hours indicating cited to
toxicity and this corresponds well to
the diminished ATP levels and
mitochondrial dysfunction seen in the
previous slides when we consider the
interplay between intracellular ATP
levels and active eco release it appears
that the cells grow under 2 D conditions
are initially able to cope effectively
with the onslaught of boobs aura at all
the concentrations however towards the
end of the study the statistically
significant increased a K and ATP levels
indicates severe cytotoxicity on the
other hand intracellular ATP levels and
a ke release from the steroids indicates
cytotoxic effects and the loss of
survivability as a result of treatment
with bizarre on the spirits for all
experimental groups but in particular
the 730 milligrams per kilogram
treatment there is also an attempt of
the swearwords treated with 200 350 and
500 milligrams per kilogram extract to
recover from each successive dosage
administered as we found the resort to
be toxic during short term use at high
dosages we attempted to conduct a
subchronic study of 21 days on FG 2 c 3
a square roots and thus prague dually
rad modem the figure presented here
indicated a significant concentration
dependent growth inhibition following
treatment with Ozora
at birth 200 milligrams per kilogram and
250 milligrams per kilogram when
compared to the untreated control group
the experimental group treated with 10
grams per kilogram while Prague acid
showed even more
stinks of growth inhibition this growth
inhibition corresponds well to the
previous study with Azara
and other studies with Rothberg acid at
various concentrations the intracellular
ATP levels expressed relative to the
third service area are depicted in the
figure on the left there was a sharp
increase in ATP levels for all
experimental groups within the first 24
hours but they decreased to lead
decreased to levels below that of the
untreated control group after 48 hours
ATP levels for the wall Prague as a
positive control remained below the
untreated control group decreasing daily
from day 5 to 14 by day 14 the
intracellular ATP levels for the
valproic acid group was significantly
lower than that of the untreated control
as well as the Ozora experimental groups
following treatment with a various
concentrations of Zorah
the intracellular ATP levels increased
post-treatment
but decreased prior to each successive
treatment by day 19 and 21 ATP levels
increased significantly when compared to
the untreated control group and this may
be indicated of an attempt of the
spirits to recover from the continuous
onslaught of treatment with crude Ozora
this cup corresponds well with the
short-term study the figure on the right
shows the active okay release per spirit
surface area an inverted trend can be
observed between the a K released and
the intracellular ATP levels a K release
appears to have decreased for all
experimental groups relative to the
untreated control within the first 24
hours post treatment a K increased
levels above the untreated control for
the valproic acid while remaining below
the entry to control for Azara groups on
day 6 there was a significant increase
in a k4 all the experimental groups but
by day 7
he a cannibals for all the experimental
groups decreased to levels lower than
that of the untreated control again
eggie levels remained below the
untreated control group from day seven
to fourteen folio press for the approach
as a treatment group but on days 15 17
19 and 21 the IQ levels once again
increased above that of the control
untreated control the ACO release for
the Ozora
treated groups remained lower than that
of the untreated control for most part
of the remaining remaining treatment
period again we notice an interplay
between intracellular ATP levels and a
ke released the increase and subsequent
decrease in intracellular ATP levels and
the increase in a co release by the
spirit streets of the valproic acid is
indicated of the toxic effect of this
known HIPPA toxin and the law since our
viability with continuous administration
they are results also indicated an
initial loss of survivability and
increased toxicity for both
concentrations of crude Zahra aqueous
extract
in this proctoring rat model we found it
ethically challenging to have daily
measurements as we did in the spheroid
model with us made use of biochemical
markers used clinically and the
diagnosis of liver injuries caused by a
potox ins Oberman total bilirubin and
ALP levels for all the various
experimental groups remained unchanged
following treatment with Zahra extract a
250 milligram per kilogram ast levels
increased relative to the untreated
control group for the male participants
on day 7 and on day 21 for the female
participants
well I our t levels were increased at
all time points compared to the
untreated control group the valproic
acid group also had increased ast and
alt levels of the 14 and 21 days
treatment for both male and female test
subjects treatment with Zahra at 250
milligrams per kilogram showed increased
LDH levels for both male and female
participants on day 7 and for male
participants on day 21 the increased al
LDH levels were also seen for the male
participants of the 200 milligram per
kilogram crude Ozora extract treatment
group on day 21 when compared to the
control group the valproic acid treated
test subjects also showed a communitive
increase in LDH levels from day 14 to 21
for both the male and female
participants furthermore an increase in
triglyceride levels were observe at all
time points following treatment with 250
milligrams per kilogram crude is our
extract and also on day 14 for the
individuals treated with 200 milligrams
per kilogram crude Mizoram the roll
break as a treatment group showed only a
slight increase in triglyceride levels
on day 14 and 21 so now we come to the
conclusion
for the both experiments we made the
following conclusion in the first the 2d
versus the 3d we could conclude that the
Azara extract showed an acute toxic
effect at dosages between 500 and 750
milligrams per kilogram Lazzara at 350
500 and 750 milligrams per kilogram also
presented with significant anti
proliferating effects when considering
the behavior of the 3d and 2d screening
models the result suggests that the 3d
cell culture model may be a superior
model in the elucidation of possible
herbal toxicity compared to the
conventional 2d cell culture model due
to the lack of the physiological
relevance of the 2d model discrepancies
in the data obtained from the 2d and the
3d models indicate that the 2d model may
result in initial false positive and
later false negative results as the data
suggests that the 2d model initially
showed limited toxicity possibly due to
the different modes of DNA repair
systems in the exponential growth phase
however as the cells into the declined
phase of the growth curve in the 2d
cultures they seem to be also severely
affected by the Ozora at all
concentration concentrations hence a
positive a false positive in the 3ds
swearword model the majority of the
cells within the spheroid structure are
predominantly non-dividing and only a
few cells are believed to be in the g1
phase of the cell cycle the later
correlates well to the in vivo situation
and intact organs whistles are also at
various stages of the cell cycle or
non-dividing suggesting that a 3d spirit
model will give a more accurate
representation of how organ in this
instance the lever will respond to Erb
such as whose aura
the results of the study between the 3d
model and the sprach dolly to further
evaluate the subchronic use of Ozora
yielded the following both the in vitro
3d spheroid model and the strobe dolly
model was able to predict moderate
hepatotoxic potential of bazzara
this results confirmed the usefulness of
hg t c3 i sweared culture models to
effectively and reliably predict
potential hippety toxic toxicity
following long-term exposure to
compounds this model therefore offers a
readily available in vitro model capable
of bridging the gap between current two
dimension in vitro screening models and
the preclinical in vivo animal models
implementing this screening model in the
preclinical evaluation process of neo
drug entities could therefore reduce
cost and time as well as the use of
animal models with compounds the use of
animal models in the testing of
compounds with potential hepatotoxic
properties we are not the only
laboratory the Borah Tori's to have
found discrepancies in terms of results
obtained from 2d and 3d experiments when
evaluating anti-cancer compounds TYIN
colleagues found that the human
pancreatic cancer cells grown as 3d
microgravity suits were more resistant
to apoptosis than that of the 2d
counterparts and exhibited lc50 values
of known anti-cancer compounds closer to
the levels observed in vivo Breslin and
Driscoll also found this to be true
furthermore a study by Lama and
colleagues comparing the ic50 values of
41 known anti-cancer drugs for non-small
lung cell cancer grown in 2d and in 3-d
swear words showed that they were very
low correlation underlying the
importance of culture technologies and
these are only a few of the available
results indicating a need for a
dimension shift in cell
culture you can decide for yourself now
does dimension really met him thank you
thank you dr. Kaulitz for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click the
send button or speaker we'll follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started
question here why did you go through two
dimensional and three dimensional
experimental groups in milligrams per
kilogram that is a very interesting
question and thank you I think the most
common problem we have when we want to
move over from in vitro studies to in
vivo studies is that you cannot directly
take the dosage and give it to an animal
it has to be extrapolated to an animal
based on its its mass so what we decided
to do is we decided to characterize r3d
swear words and our 2d cultures in terms
of protein content or spirit size and
then with those are our experiments in
terms of that making it easier when we
do go over to in vivo studies to just
take that dosage and then the results
are more comparable because you're
giving exactly the same dosage to the
cells that you are giving to the animals
it's not like you're giving a large
amount to cells because if I give a
large amount of compound to assult it
will obviously be the toxic however now
I'm giving the exact amount of compound
to the cells and the animals and that is
why we moved over to milligrams per
kilogram thank you thank you for
explaining that I would like to once
again thank dr. Collins for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possum
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December
27th 2018 you'll receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye